Hey youtubers it’s charlie and game of thrones
just posted it’s second trailer for season
4 with some new footage so just like last
time I wanted to do a breakdown of all the
new stuff.
In case you’re finding me for the first
time I’ll be doing a special season 4 countdown
video series starting in about two weeks.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
I’ll be doing histories of the great houses,
character videos and what ever else you guys
want to see.
I’m also doing a Q&A video Monday, so I’ll
be picking 10 or 11 questions from the comments
on this video to answer in a video.
Careful for potential spoilers in case you
don’t want to know anything.
Now on to the important stuff, somebody blow
the dragon horn.
First, the big difference is the voice over
narration.
Arya starts by saying her prayer and explaining
it to the hound.
She adds names to it as she goes along.
So by the end of this season, there will be
more names on it.
Then there’s the first shot of styr, the
magnar of thenn.
He’s played by Joseph Gatt.
A lot of his parts from book 3 were given
to the lord of bones last season, but he’s
finally arrived to the party.
Number 3Then sophie turner shares a post-red
wedding moment with tyrion.
She didnt’ have a lot of time to grieve
as her wedding to tyrion was kind of rushed.
She had a lot to cry about last season, but
it seems like she’s mostly over the tyrion
part and is just grieving about her family
now.
Number 4 - Jon Snow talks about the old bear
being murdered by burn gorman and the other
rogue night’s watchmen.
Burn Gorman is actually returning this season.
So Jon may get a chance to revenge.
If you didn’t know Jeor Mormot is the father
of ser jorah mormot who’s serving dany in
the east right now.
Number 5 - There’s the first speaking scene
from Stannis.
He’s drunk Melisandre’s kool-aide so much
that he’s dedicated to the idea of this
epic war between the red god and the great
other.
I always love how all of his scenes usually
have burning flame in them.
Number 6 - Here’s a shot of dany’s legions
unsullied attacking mereen.
It’s hard to tell until you see that bit
of debri fly by.
Number 7 - Here’s another shot of the wilding
seige against the night’s watch.
Number 8 - There’s a voice over and scene
from littlefinger talking to sansa about revenge.
If there’s anything littlefinger has been
good at it’s the art of the long con.
He’s like the great gatsby type person of
game of thrones.
He loved catyln stark but she was too far
above him.
So he rose to power and dedicated himself
to crushing the people he hated like the baratheons
and the lannisters and creating a world where
he would be able to be with her.
And ended up going a little mad in the process.
Number 9 - Cersei spits tyrion’s line back
in his face.
The day will come when your joy will turn
to ashes in your mouth and you will know the
debt is paid. is something tyrion said to
her during season 2.
Number 10 - This is the first shot of shae
we’ve seen in season 4.
It cuts trait to a scene of tywin which for
book readers is a huge teaser of a major plot
point.
So I won’t say what it is.
Number 11 - Dany declares that she will rule.
This is her dedicating herself to fixing the
problems of slavering and terrible government
in the east.
She’s faced with the choice of abandoning
her quest for the iron throne or helping all
the people she’s liberated.
Number 12 - And it ends on a shot of a white
walker.
This is the first season 4 shot we’ve seen
of one and it looks like a different one than
we saw last year.
So they may have changed the makeup effects
just to make them all a little more unique.
Because white walkers are just a different
race of people just like the other nations
of essos.
So looking at all this it looks like they’re
really pushing the valar morghulis theme this
season.
ALL men must die, as in everyone must die.
Special shout out for dany’s line from last
season though, when she responded “yes but
we are not men”.
So now it’s your turn, let me know what
your favorite moment was from the new trailer.
And what are your biggest questions.
I have to say my favorite shot was definitely
them giving cersei tyrion’s line and that
last shot of the white walker.
Remember I’ll be picking your questions
from the comments to include in my Q&A video
tomorrow night.
I’m also posting walking dead tonight too.
Right now click here for all my other game
of thrones breakdowns and click here for my
latest walking dead episode.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!